[Music]
doctors fresh out of medical school
could work around the clock under new
rules but this is raising concerns about
patient safety the scheduled changes
taking effect this Saturday increased
the 16-hour shift limit for first-year
residents to 24 hours dr. Tara Narula
Jewett shows us what it means for
patients and for their doctors Tara good
morning good morning this issue has been
under the microscope for three decades
the ideal working hours for both medical
care and on-the-job training 30,000
first-year residents start work July 1st
although the new rules could add eight
or more hours to their shifts many are
actually welcoming the longer days
Melissa guru Thursday starts at 5:00
a.m. when she reports four rounds at
Long Island Jewish Medical Center
during her first year as a doctor she's
required to clock out after sixteen
hours even when she wants to stay longer
I don't want to say oh you know I'm
leaving for the day but the night
interns going to come and check on you I
want to be the one doing that critical
patient information is relayed during
handoff to the incoming chef shorter
shifts increased handoffs bringing more
opportunities for error and
interruptions to doctor training medical
emergencies not all occur between 8:00
and 4:00 dr. Rowan said Herrmann helped
update the rules to bring training in
line with the realities of hospital care
and when you had one resident that was
only there 16 hours and another resident
that was there 24 it interferes with the
team-based care that occurs under the
new rules first year residents can
choose to stay even longer than 24 hours
to an average maximum of 80 hours per
week keep in mind in terms of just
graduated medical school they're the
least experienced to the least
knowledgeable members of the medical
team caring for patients dr. Sammy Alma
shot tracks doctor training for Public
Citizen so what has been considered a
rite of passage working longer hours
being strong can actually be detrimental
to the patient and the resident yes
that's what the evidence shows
unequivocally a Harvard study found that
residents made almost 36 percent more
serious medical errors when working
four hours or longer they're coming up
against the limits of their of their
capacity to function and all they can
think about is sleep about to start year
to dr. guru therus says extended hours
might have enhanced her first year
training I can read about it I can watch
YouTube I can do anything from home but
it's not gonna be the same as you know
being bedside with a patient so you
haven't heard a lot of commiserating
amongst the residents about how many
hours you have to work and about fatigue
obviously some people get we can get
tired I think that the idea of the
intern is a creature that lives in the
hospital and comes out after 30 hours in
like a dark closet I think that's kind
of archaic now keep up the good work a
key goal of the new rules is to help
doctors become more invested in their
patients by avoiding a shift work
mentality so I go to talk to you in the
green room before you come on and I said
who could possibly think this is a great
idea and you go I actually do and all of
us at the table going what I know it's
complicated issues definitely are
exhausted but I do think it can enhance
learning because you're there to see the
arc of the disease and you do feel more
invested in the patient because it's
like your family you want to show you
everywhere you are you are a higher
earning but what about the patient's
quality well you're training doctors for
the rest of their life though so you
want to make sure they're you know as
well-trained as possible preserving
safety for Thank You Terry okay doctor